S
UNBELIEVABLE.
HUGE STORY, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WE'RE NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT THE
DAILY MAIL AND STARTED BREAKING
MORE REAL NEWS THAN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THAT'S THE
CASE NOW, WE DON'T READ IT.
CHECK IT OUT AND YOU'LL SEE IT'S
TRUE.
THEY REPORTED LAST WEEK ON
MESSAGES BETWEEN HUNTER BIDEN
AND IN ASSISTANT WHO APPARENTLY
HAS BEEN TIED TO THE INTELLIGENT
SERVICES OF CHINA.
IT INCLUDED ADVICE FOR THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
JOSH BOSWELL, AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON AND CONGRATS
ON THE STORY BY THE WAY.
>> I WONDER WHY IT FELL TO A
FOREIGN NEWS SOURCE TO REPORT
THIS, BUT THANK YOU FOR DOING
IT.
WHAT DO THE MESSAGES TELL US?
>> SO, THESE EMAILS AND TEXT
MESSAGES I FOUND ON HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP WERE REALLY QUITE
INTRIGUING AND TO SET THE
BACKDROP FOR YOU, YOU'VE GOT
HUNTER BIDEN IN 2017 STRIKING UP
THIS JOINT VENTURE WITH A
CHINESE OIL AND GAS COMPANY, AND
HE ENTERED INTO THIS JOINT
VENTURE, THE SECRETARY GENERAL
OF THE COUNTRY OF THE COMPANY IS
A GUY CALLED PATRICK.
HUNTER GETS ASSIGNED THIS
ASSISTANT, JIAQI BAO, CHINESE
AMERICA, 29 AT THE TIME.
YOU CAN SEE IT FIRST AND NORMAL
MESSAGES AND YOU KIND OF
PERSONAL ASSISTANT WOULD SEND
DOCTORS APPOINTMENTS, HOTEL
BOOKINGS, FLIGHT BOOKINGS, THEN
IT GETS TO BECOME MORE AND MORE
PERSONAL.
THE TURNING POINT REALLY IS WHEN
YOU SEE PATRICK, THE
SECRETARY GENERAL, GET ARRESTED
BY THE FEDS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
NOVEMBER, 2017 OVER BRIBERY,
CORRUPTION
CHARGES.
HIS ASSISTANT STARTED SENDING
UNDER THESE EMAILS ASKING WHAT'S
GOING ON?
SHE WANTS DETAILED INFORMATION
ON THE CASE.
KIND OF STRANGE FOR SOMEONE IN A
JUNIOR POSITION.
THEN YOU CAN SEE MORE PERSONAL
EMAILS COME OUT AS WELL, SHE
JOKES WITH HIM, SHE TELLS HIM
THE DRINKS ARE ON HER, SHE SAYS
THAT SHE BECAME CLOSE TO HIM AND
ENDS UP WITH HIS MILITARY DOG
TAPES DEMAND DEMONIC DOGTAGS IN
HER
APARTMENT BUT AS IT GOES ON, AFT
VENTURE STARTS TO COLLAPSE,
BECAUSE OF THE ARREST OF PATRICK
AND ALSO THE ARREST UNREST IN
CHINA BECAUSE OF THE LEADER, YON
SEE HER EMAILING HUNTER WITH ALL
THE IDEAS.
SHE SENT HIM A BUNCH OF
OPPOSITION RESEARCH TO HELP
JOE BIDEN AND HIS PRESIDENTIAL
BID.
IT'S ON FOR THAT TO BE COMING
FROM A 29-YEAR-OLD SECRETARY.
>> Tucker: YEAH, MAYBE I